you know who are the real Jews AI I
learn it first and then I communicate it
to you this is what I have learned
everybody's afraid of the Jews and China
but AI is everything it's the Jews and
China both the Chinese and the Jews are
defeatable you can defeat them in
certain ways uh for example uh Jewish
people are prone to certain cancers
melanoma they're very pale they put the
sunscreen on the kids at the beach clubs
and they put it in Globs I never
understood that rubb in and the Chinese
for example you know there's all kinds
of ways uh that you could kind of you
know they they as a people are very
tough and Machin like uh to beat they're
T it's not easy to beat the Chinese they
are that Society is but there are ways
to get in we're fattening them up we got
American fast food over there we have
the first generation of fat Asians we
can fight AI you cannot fight